unrack heart by the way so happy
hardware ahead now
hi I'm Greg and I made Nate he
understands that say his name unlike
everyone else that goes on this channel
Nate I met at a comedy show uh-huh true
is the host of this comedy show it's
[ __ ] hysterical thank you thank you
so much and he was the best audience
member in the crowd cracking them [ __ ]
up he's really funny
thank you saw on and off the stage
mm-hmm yeah there's no facade years nope
no really amp I don't need to tell you
on this we didn't see ya oh he's also an
actual working actor and right you've
been on the gear like yeah 16 episodes
going on go but yeah so I did a via ABC
show the Goldbergs check your local
listings right away today your drillbit
Taylor and role models about yours I
mean one of the main kids and drillbit
Taylor it's true speaking of acting
you've heard of a man named Bradley Pitt
right oh yeah oh yeah
my favorite war machine you know I
haven't seen it I haven't seen this
either and let's watch it Morrow I see
you're the man who will get the job done
okay so the business between the people
in it they don't look like me there's a
leader of US forces in Afghanistan and
you have spoken to the president
launched in 70 day yes general you must
know is a war you will never win it may
help you Oh peachy phone call Ward way
he happened
what oh nice Netflix shows are so short
dude
Netflix is like just King everything
they're interested enough freezes no
good to go into theaters today ms dhoni
all gonna be doing such good content
there's like in oh my god so we got
Ferris Bueller going on in that way yeah
that's it
we got tildes winger going on we God we
have the guy from The Maze Runner and
we're the Millers yeah I forgot that
little just call him Maze Runner Miller
Brad Pitt it looks like a great
distinguished gray look at he's got gray
hair he's looking like a handsome One
almost grandpa it looks fake to me to a
greater girl is really big doesn't it so
ruin it really just thank you it was the
accent every time he's in a war movie
yeah like inglorious bastards fury mmm
it is general every time he's like some
type of general they say max it is for
their hon I look at Aldo right yes those
good if you're one of you here
oh yeah it's insane a Ben Kingsley's in
this cool Oh [ __ ] venom himself so for
Grace's in this old my gosh I don't know
what this movies about a satire of
America's war with Afghanistan with a
focus on the people running the campaign
sold so don't like the exact a county
imagine you had me at a marriage Brad
Pitt is like never goes wrong and
honestly Netflix has been cranking out
some really good stuff so Netflix is uh
they're producing doing Martin
Scorsese's next time you hear about this
know what's up it's the Irish man
Irishman okay no I stars De Niro Pacino
Joe Pesci and Harvey Keitel and it's got
another hundred five million dollar
Netflix okay that's real then sing it up
I can't even know how can we go to the
theater system is totally crap that's
awesome my Janeiro's but I don't do his
voice but I can do his face just really
bigger bolder they're all right there's
the finger no no boys I'm wondering like
would with a list guy directed things
animal kingdom yeah that is actually
very good I think it was not many for
Oscar it's Australian oh dude that's
actually a really great movie yeah it's
about like these like gangster brothers
all and then guys in it I'm from place
beyond the pines the what's his name
please beyond the pines guy giving up
everything it's an interesting movie
about like since they're making humor as
a series and I think yeah about how war
is a business yeah and they're making
like some comment yeah man but that is
that translates I mean I think I hope
the message here is is peace yeah as
opposed to making light of the
explosions I water Jersey really yeah
really more really warm who isn't really
hurting it's such an edgy material it
could go past the line of just yeah
what's the word like you got offensive
comedy then too much coming yeah it
literally just a spinoff of Iron Man
yeah that's what most people right oh
well we're getting a thrill up a donkey
we are really excited men can't power at
my corner I do without you alright guys
well you can subscribe is a real reject
you can follow made heart Harley Hartley
Harvey you can fine you can follow to
the raagh
this isn't all Bob this is odd or you
know my last night hey hardly they'd
hardly follow me I'm not a big heart is
a all curly I love you you can catch
them on TV
so watch TV I know Daisy actually me and
YouTube at the same time eight on TV and
watch it in a theater where a line is
right is taking play that as well let's
get as much more that's going on and
enjoy your life and spread love oh and
last thing this was requested by a
special someone and no one was it Oprah
Oprah is actually a huge fan of
reactions yeah oh yeah you get a few
yeah I'll get up you you have a lot of
porn on this computer I'm trying to quit
Billy Meachem he requested this video
okay cool so shout out to you Billy
Meachem Billy you can go to sleep happy
tonight you blow a lot of kisses whoa
that's like a kiss you're gonna blow up
Yeah right